surely there's nothing that can go wrong
by building up years of hype before
finally releasing a long anticipated
sequel
I mean kingdom of the Crystal Skull
lived up to everything Indiana Jones
fans were hoping for Independence Day
resurgence Zoolander - the critics of
all those movies agreed that the wait
between movies was probably the best
thing for the series rights clearly I
have nothing to worry about with this
episode
[Music]
hello internet welcome to food
sorry my cat said on the Heike so in
last week's part 2 of this epic Whovian
adventure we continued our quest to lay
out point by point the reasons why Time
Lords could technically walk among us
wait what you're saying it wasn't last
week you're telling me it was two years
ago oh no that doesn't sound right are
you sure you didn't fall into a TARDIS
or something maybe you don't need proof
the Time Lords exist because you are the
Time Lord now not buying it okay well
here's the real story for those of you
who haven't been subscribed since
literally the day this channel launched
we've done to Doctor Who theories in the
past the distant past the very far
distant past the first two months of
this channeled past and if you haven't
seen them you should probably go watch
him now I guess I don't know they were
from the infancy of this channel who
even knows what I was doing back in 2015
but this is a part three so did not at
least help you find parts 1 & 2 of the
series 78 videos later would be pretty
mean of me you can find both of those in
the I icon and upper right hand corner
of the screen which begs the question of
why did it take me over 2 years to
release the third theory maybe I needed
to do some time-travel research of my
own maybe the feds were trying to
silence me about Time Lords maybe I'm
working on launching a new theory
Channel or maybe just maybe the script
has been written the entire time but I
was never fully satisfied with the
content contained in the episode not
feeling substantial enough for a
full-fledged theory that would be
believable to you guys could be any one
of those who knows maybe just leave that
one up to you guys to theorize about but
regardless the time is here now because
enough people at VidCon Australia
pestered me about it and I can finally
finally reveal to you all the truth Time
Lords are real there's not just evidence
for one or two of them oh no sir
crawling around the internet is actually
evidence of a ton of these guys popping
in and out of time and space from simple
entertainers like Nicolas Cage who's
made appearances as far back as the
American Civil War no wait earlier as a
member of the famous Habsburg family or
the man we currently know as Keanu
Reeves popping in as early as the 8th
century as Charlemagne yeah Charlemagne
himself
whoa think it's just a Hollywood movie
star conspiracy well think again major
little figurehead Vladimir Putin
mysteriously doesn't seem to have aged
into over a hundred years he's been on
the planet earth and Mark Zuckerberg is
mysteriously also Prince Philip the
fourth of Spain but this could all be
just doppelgangers right mirror
look-alike Oh Peter Dinklage really does
look like Diego Velazquez
holy cow should this episode just be
about him wait wait don't lose focus
matpat oh these other schmoes are just
fun look-alikes from the course of
history
none of these Time Lord candidates
compared to the most well-documented
contestant for Time Lord status comb to
descend you man
never heard of him well let me make some
introductions since you'll be seeing him
in your past present and future from now
on comb to Sanja man or just count of
st. Germain for those of you who failed
French class was your quintessential
Renaissance man born in theory in 1691
he was reportedly the son of Prince
Francis the second record Chi rag code
Chi Rick Rocco's ski the record see
Prince Francis the second of
Transylvania which can we be honest will
always be every other place for
spookiest country contest it turns out
that Transylvania isn't just Dracula's
favorite destination it's also home to
some pretty creepy time travelers as
well so while our buddy called Djimon
lived there he was a locally well-known
philosopher artist scientist and
musician that in and of itself isn't
crazy since we know other people in
history like Leonardo da Vinci have been
Renaissance men but take a closer look
at the counts public facing life and you
start to see there's more to this man
that meets the eye a friend of his
Giacomo Casanova wrote in his memoirs
that the count would regularly talk
about knowing quote the secret of
universal medicine that he possessed a
mastery over nature that he could melt
diamonds and have the ability to form
out of ten or twelve small diamonds one
large one and at dinner parties the
count was known to talk about historical
figures like Cleopatra and Henry the
eighth as if he knew them personally
when sceptical historians would try to
trip the count up by questioning him
about tiny historical details the count
would always reply with remarkable
accuracy leaving everyone dumbfounded by
how much he seemed to know about people
from completely different times and
places and remember this was hundreds of
the years before modern communication
and only a couple hundred years after
the printing press was invented so
everything to count knew about music
philosophy
medicine science and history had to have
been learned one page at a time
over the course of a lifetime well that
or experienced one day at a time as you
travel through an eternal life span it's
okay he knows more than he showed about
a few things and claims to know the
secrets of science and medicine is that
Time Lord worthy it isn't on its own but
then consider this the really funny
thing about our buddy the count is that
no one really knew where he came from in
fact while it was said that he was the
son of Prince Francis the second row
grah grah of Transylvania the only
person who claimed this was the count
himself and when he was pressed for an
answer as to his origins he told people
he was five hundred years old I mean
really imagine that conversation hello
where did you go to school and five
hundred years old I was born before
University is worth thing oh my I bet
Greek life really blew chunks back then
in my day Greek life was still being
lived by the Greeks 500 years old you're
really not getting this are you on top
of that he claimed to have been present
at very specific historic events during
his 500 year lifespan he told people he
had a room in the Tower of London in the
1300s that he claimed to have studied
alchemy in France in the 1400s and even
if you don't go with drunk person at a
party history even the real documented
parts of his life seemed to play into
his claims according to tangible
historical records that do exist he was
actually born in 1691 and died in 1784
at the age of 91 now that's a pretty
amazing lifespan for someone in the 17th
century we're not just talking about one
guy who lived a particularly long time
in history instead what we're looking at
is a man who's capable of going wherever
he wants or whenever he wants during
that life under tons of different
aliases he went by dozens of different
names the Marquis de Montferrat colt de
belem our Shevek Chevalier Shona count
Weldon count salt sold coughed grabs our
goat cheese grafts ROG and prints prints
rag ghosts key give up I give up on that
list just the name of you and the
hardest view he was apparently fluent in
French and German spokes and polish was
learning English but was most
comfortable speaking Spanish or
Portuguese besides being able to take on
all kinds of different backgrounds and
names though this guy also shows up all
over the place he was
minted in London during the Jacobite
revolution showed up in French court
with Louis the 15th he negotiated peace
in Holland during the Seven Years War
all this time he was known as a wealthy
aristocrat who had major art and book
collections that he kept in his royal
estate so when he supposedly died they
found almost no possessions on him he
did all this travelling participated in
major historical events all across
Europe met some of the most famous
people in the world but didn't keep any
sort of memorabilia souvenirs nothing no
artwork no library of books no castles
no snow globe in fact the town he died
and had to action off what little stuff
he had six months after his funeral
because no living relative came to claim
any of it none of it adds up to what
most people would claim believable from
one guy's lifetime and he's still not
done even after death over the years
after his supposed death he also just
kept right on popping up at major
historical events in 1793 he supposedly
appeared at the execution of Marie
Antoinette and in 1799 there was an
account of him being present in the
French ports during Napoleon's national
coup in 1820 on the night before Charles
Ferdinand was murdered the countess
Tatem are reported visiting but then in
1870 Napoleon the third was apparently
so interested in this quote-unquote
undying count that he had a special
commission put together to collect
information on it but all those records
were mysteriously lost in a fire in 1871
only one year later in 1914 two Bavarian
soldiers claimed to have captured him
during World War one and on and on and
on with his latest appearance being as
late as the 1960s at a political
conference in Berlin so Time Lords exist
there on record call it case closed
everyone we got him 14th official doctor
confirmed but not so fast honestly when
I was scripting this episode many years
ago and now today this is where I wanted
to end it with Time Lords existing and
Doctor Who being totally plausible in
real life
but while researching it I'd be lying if
I didn't say I came across some ideas
that cast a bit of doubt onto this whole
time Lord conspiracy and that the
episode itself felt incomplete without
discussing why this obviously probably
isn't a real thing what if I could not
only tell you why we think Time Lords
exist but why we like to believe they
in the first place it turns out when we
create conspiracies like about Keanu
Reeves having previous lives we're
actually engaging at a kind of
intellectual gymnastics famous
psychologist Kirby Ferrell has written
pretty extensively about conspiracies
and how putting together the pieces of
conspiracy puzzles give humans the same
kind of satisfaction as putting together
something like a complex jigsaw puzzle
or solving a difficult logic problem it
makes us smarter it helps us to feel
more empowered and it actually makes us
better equipped to solve problems in the
real world like programming computers
building car engines and learning music
in the research ferrell is done he's
actually found that people who buy into
conspiracy theories aren't the wide-eyed
rubes you might think they are in fact
it's the complete opposite people who
tend to love conspiracy theories like I
don't know people who watch online
videos proving that their favorite
characters from all sorts of media are
secretly evil they're not the gullible
ones they tend to be the skeptics of the
world whether they're cynical about
something in life or just don't take
what they're told at face value even in
the face of social pressures people who
look for conspiracies tend to form their
own opinions and buy into conspiracies
on their own does that mean the
conspiracies are right most of the time
know what conspiracy theories are just
that is the count of st. Germain a real
Time Lord maybe and then again he was
probably just a really good liar who
read a lot of history books sounded like
he knew what he was talking about and
left a pretty hefty reputation behind
him if you stop and look at the facts it
was actually common for nobility to go
by multiple names so they could avoid
talking to people that they didn't like
it was also common for them to travel
around Europe and then inflate their
stories about their own travels hashtag
bragging rights
there was no fact-checking at that time
so all he had to do to convince other
people he was smart was just convincing
whoever was in the room with him and all
those historical accounts of him
appearing after he died well several of
them were from an unhinged woman who
fantasized about him after his death the
others were reporting from high-stress
situations like the battlefield in World
War one and political negotiations
during the Cold War when you unpack a
lot of conspiracies you find that the
majority of them are explained by simple
if kind of disappointing logic but at
the end of the day my point here is that
that might not actually be what matters
here what matters is that you ask
question in the first place that you saw
evidence out there and you didn't take
your own assumptions at face value and
for all you who viens out there who've
been waiting two years for this episode
well one of the defining characteristics
of that show is its constant ability to
redefine your expectations keep you
curious and keep you trying to put the
pieces of the puzzle together and a
person who's skeptical of what they're
told
looks for the facts themselves and comes
to their own opinions off of those facts
that's the type of person this world
needs now more than ever so maybe the
two year wait was worth it but hey
that's just a theory
Oh film theory and cut
hold up you waited two years for this
episode and now that you've watched it
you've got a whole nother month before
the Doctor Who Christmas special so what
are you gonna do with your time you why
me love themselves to fill the gap how
about watching another sci-fi series
about people who travel through time to
save the lives of others wow that sounds
a lot like Doctor Who I hear you saying
and yes yes it is but it's even better
because it's here on YouTube right now
all you need are two words life line
well it's two words but they're fused
together into one bigger word a compound
word technically lifeline is all about a
company that sends its agents 33 days
into the future to save the lives of
people that they know are gonna die and
like mini Time Lords and training one
agent fails to save his wife's life and
suddenly it becomes a manhunt and not
only is it a cool concept that perfectly
matches your interests and Doctor Who
but it's also a series done by my
personal friends Sam and Nico from the
channel corridor digital who if you're
not familiar have been pioneers of high
quality effects driven videos since the
earliest days of YouTube I love these
guys I love their work and I think that
you're gonna love them too so check out
their new series lifeline the first
episode is available right now just wave
your little sonic screwdriver up the
link you see on screen or click the link
in the description and then keep your
eyes locked on the screen like it's an
angel statue and heck if you like it
you've got yourself eight 30-minute
episodes to fill your time enough to
keep you busy until the premiere of the
first ever female doctor in December now
if you'll excuse me I need to start
working on another
of episodes the third part of which will
come out years after it's relevant
see you then